Ryan congratulations first on this
accomplishment thank you yeah it's I'm
excited you said that this is this is
just the halfway mark for you what's
next hopefully many more years you know
I look at my idol Norman Lear who's
alive and kickin and creating in his 90s
and yeah I think a lot of times when
people get stars on the Walk of Fame
they think well maybe this is you know
the pinnacle the pinnacle and I don't
feel that way I'm excited about so many
things and I and creating so many new
things I have the politician with
Gwyneth and Ben Platt coming out in the
fall and then I have ratchet with Sarah
Paulson I'm developing a lot of things I
have another season opposed that I'm
getting ready to start shooting so I
just like to be busy and create as you
know you talk about just different
initiatives your philanthropy pose gives
back today great announcement tell us
about that post kiss back I mean well I
wanted to donate the profits opposed to
trans organizations which we've done and
also we're gonna allocate some of the
funds to supporting our own people and
politicians who see us and believe that
we and our community have the same basic
human rights as everybody and I think
that's something to be supported and
sought out and encouraged so I vowed to
do that to help our actors in our
community you know who really just need
a champion and a leader sometimes the
phantom wants to know Ryan American
Horror Story apocalypse part 2 we want
we need our witches back the witches
will be back not next season though but
we have something really fun planned
it's exclusive I can't say what it is
all right did this luncheon and many of
the horror story actors are there and
I'm gonna tell them for the first time
so I have to tell them for
[Music]